guys what is sexual assault again the
feminist infiltrated the legal system
and it brought in all of these
definitions that we don't know what they
mean so they essentially expanded the
definition of sexual assault rape this
is what they do they come into these
these spaces and change the definitions
and make them more subjective not
objective so it's more subjective
whether or not someone was sexually
assaulted like think about it guys what
is sexual assault even mean
what does it even mean dude like just
off the top of your head we should know
in a society what words mean but what
the feminists do is they get into these
systems change the definitions and
confuse everybody